[Applause]
i mean come on so podcasts are like i i
didn't want to do a podcast for so long
because i was like i just feel like i'm
okay yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm just i'm
also very speechless staring at you was
a very intense experience borderline
demoralizing but how did she get that
much makeup on her face dude i
you don't look like you're wearing a lot
of makeup that's what's weird i guess i
just um you know people always when
people see me with no makeup on
sometimes they go oh you look so much
younger why don't you uh not wear makeup
anymore i'm like but i don't want to
look younger and i like makeup it's fun
bitch i know why do i feel like this is
gonna was a wide wide open i feel like
we're getting way hotter as we get older
i mean some things are better i feel
definitely like i'm getting smarter yeah
finally
yeah i finally stopped dating malignant
narcissists yeah i mean i always feel
like i'm getting better in a lot of ways
in life and what i do
um but you know then there's somebody
that come along and tell you like you're
starting to look old you know social
media they're like people
i don't know are you hanging out with me
i mean like on social media or something
like you just like suddenly you're like
i feel good and then suddenly you're
like oh yeah i mean that's someone that
it just will never be able to sleep with
you right so they're like that's why i'm
not gonna do it yeah yeah when they when
they make it their idea
that they're not dating you i love all
my banned words on socials my favorite
news
you can so that you just get it's like
people are leaving the same kind of
comments over and over again like trolls
and stuff like q and on little like you
know um uh uh harems q of q anon boys
you can block certain words that are
like your most
it took me a second to understand this
so
i'm dying to know what yours were mine
were
like comments i was getting so often
words and comments that i just blocked
the word all together
busted
cunt probably
uh
unfuckable
big one which is by the way but if i
don't want to fuck you i don't care that
you don't you know what i mean it's just
this thing of like you're on i'm not
going to fuck you it's like oh i didn't
like realize uh uh that i was going for
your approval do you know what i'm
saying like
when they've made the decision to stop
dating you
in their comment you're like oh god okay
sorry i guess we're broken up i got too
old um and then uh and then like female
comics names like other female comments
i have a bunch of names banned as well
can i ask no
can i guess i mean well you could
probably guess right right right right
like you could guess like a certain rock
star i used to be married to 22 years
ago sure i keep getting asked about that
i don't want to be asked about but you
know yeah i've been in a situation where
i
you know we don't need to get too into
that but when someone else's behavior
all of a sudden it's like you need to
answer for it it's like how is this my
thing
you know like i think yeah when the
woman i feel like always has to answer
for stuff and it's just like
someone else yeah yeah why are you why
you talk to the people that want to talk
about it yeah correct well correct i'm
saving mine for my book yeah there you
go bitch uh see you're very strategic
about how like mysterious you are you're
very mysterious to me and then i meet
you and you're disarming because you're
like so funny like i knew you were funny
and charming god can i put that in
quotes that you said i was funny because
i said oh i'm going to come on there and
be like i'm just i'm only funny in like
a really stupid stupid way like a like
i think you're funny incredibly well i
think to me the funniest thing is always
saying like what everybody is thinking
and no one has the balls to say did i do
that already
it was your shirt right no well there
was that you called me out of my shirt
no i love this shirt though it brought
joy to my morning thank you wow and i
mean you look like like
italian mrs claw like if you do not see
what she looks like right now have you
seen babes in toyland the movie babes in
toyland that's what she looks like she
looks like a veda and i'm literally
stuck is this what it's like to be a
straight man around women like i'm like
totally mumbling i have no idea what i'm
saying
and you're also you're and you also you
leave room see i just never stopped
talking
so you and you you just will
listen and it's very attractive i'm
gonna start doing this is this the key
to you being the greatest burlesque just
usually she's like i just figured out
just be pretty and just talk when you
need to say something right
calculating and deliberate
um no i mean i think i i'm a big fan of
yours and i listen to you i'm like i
just want to listen actually i just want
to hang out with you and not be recorded
so that we can just say everything we
want to say too yeah i know we should do
that at some point um yeah after we've
made money together we'll go like okay
now we can have a friendship off-camera
work
no i think that you are so and because i
do think that
burlesque uh
and drag are like the two art forms now
that are you can really do like
everyone's like a comedy you can't make
these jokes you can't do this like
burlesque and drag is where where we
used to be able to go
in terms of like you know i mean i don't
feel bad i feel like
there's a lot of parameters i think more
for burlesque than for drag i think drag
gets like a pass sometimes because
you know it's sometimes comedy or you
know and and i i think and also they get
a pass like with even with nudity you
know yeah yeah yeah
you know i still can't perform at any of
the big places in nashville because
um you know of the female nudity laws
and they don't exist for men so you know
i got on a call once with the nashville
theater that i wanted to do the only one
that fits my show that's big enough and
you know they said well there's a lot of
things about the nudity laws here and i
was like okay will you explain it run it
run it through for me and have you seen
my body it doesn't apply to my body the
thing that i had a pro okay obviously
like you can't show
under boob you can't wear pasties you
have to wear an illusion bra that's fine
but the thing that really got me was
they said you can't show that crease
between your leg and your
butt so you know like and i said well
can i wear like a full bikini like a
bikini like a brief you know like a 50s
brief no because you can see that crease
between the light you have to wear
something like a bike shorts and i said
well what about tights with like a
bathing suit bottle and they said under
armour bike shorts yeah bike shorts they
said a bike shorts and i remember them
some a bike shorts and i thought a
rhinestone bike shorts is interesting
but not there's something kind of
amazing to me that this is just his
fetish
and he like there's actually a woman
telling me oh this is a woman okay yeah
okay then yeah maybe she's her husband's
going to the show yeah and then the last
the other kicker was i said well you
know there's just as many men in the
show as women so what are the rules for
the men showing their bodies because you
know we have them in like little
underwear or like their boxer shorts or
anything oh there's not any rules for
the men
and i was like yeah that's what i
thought i follow a lot of girls on
instagram that live uh in nashville and
i see a lot of creases and i see a lot
of underboob um that is also wild
because as soon as you said that you're
like you can't show the crease under
your bottom like you mean my butt
yeah i was like it's because like oh
certain kind of bugs do that and i love
that he like or this person like right
some don't yeah like if you're 12 you
can show because you don't have a crease
yet yeah
no but i guess it's about the alcohol
and i was just like i don't really want
to do a sober burlesque show that does
not sound funny so they're not allowed
to have alcohol in the venue either it's
alcohol with nudity is the real problem
like in this country in different states
like there's all kinds of wild rules
benton before the shows in um when we
tour goes over all the weird laws in the
cities that we go to so he will know
yeah right and i'm from nashville so
that's why i was able to travel to
atlanta to watch you right isn't it
because we have all those rules because
at strip clubs in nashville you have to
bring your own beer
really or byob
that sounds okay and then the girls
aren't actually stripping okay they're
just like in they're just bikinis right
right
yeah weird is that where that hole came
from like kesha is a friend of mine
she's always wearing viking shirts with
cowboy boots that is kind of a thing
right now that's kind of a natural thing
not doing that yeah you're not doing
that no no you are not doing that i was
trying to actually figure out how to
make that like bike shorts like
there's nothing vintage i mean i guess
it's like a girdle maybe a girdle i
don't know or like bathing suits that
were longer right
like bathing suits that went kind of low
i mean not like that blow yeah that's
like victorian times or something that's
like
bloomers yeah bloomers shit come on
diaphanous bloomers i was also weighing
like the expense of getting new costumes
for everyone and then going do i really
need to do this do they need to change
their laws i don't need to yeah if i
accommodate them yeah can we ask what
the venue was
i don't remember but one of the big
theaters but i also know that drag race
got to go into that same venue and you
know
striptease
i was sitting there going
uh that's not cool
that's so wild
when it is state by state what is your
favorite state or or country really to
perform in i know you're in paris
i'd have to say san francisco ranks high
as far as cities that are just wild and
people go like crazy and then
london you know i do the london
palladium and i can do like six nights
sold out there and it's like 3000 or
something like that
and it's a scene you know the way people
dress up yeah the show in their the girl
it's almost all women for people that
don't know it's a burlesque show but
people that come to my show are usually
women and uh the men that are there are
usually gay or they're the husband or
you know boyfriend of the women that
want to go to a strip show so it's not
what you what people think i'm so
fascinated by i mean you are coined the
queen of burlesque you are you know
comedians we see a very specific uh side
of people's nature i also feel like you
are uniquely qualified to understand
parts of human nature that
most people just will never see or
understand like what have you learned
from human nature just from what you do
yeah well i feel like there's been a big
arc in my career from when i started in
the early 90s and i was a playboy girl
and i had you know the heterosexual male
gaze on me you know and then how that's
what i have on youtube
i put that on when you're around they
just can't help it and then that changed
drastically i think in the early 2000s
when i
wrote my first book
and then when i wrote my second book it
was suddenly i had all these like women
following me and that changed and so
it's kind of weird also to me i just got
back from dancing with the stars in
france and i was kind of you know a lot
of
like these
guys men were suddenly like really into
me again you know like because i was on
tv and i was the one with the boobs and
the you know
doing the thing
yeah costume's too small for me yeah um
and don't tell us about your book i was
suddenly like oh god i have all these
like like
like heterosexual men shaking around me
again it's like it was weird to have
that again i think that there's also a
little bit of a swing back to
you know because we see so much
nudity all the time now whenever you
want you can watch whatever and there's
something i think about you know
burlesque and what you do specifically
that is actually so much sexy we have so
much access to sex but it's not sexy you
know what i'm saying i think that
there's a real
uh you know i was um
whenever i go to my gynecologist i
always ask her like what are the new
trends like tell me everything like i
tell her like you know give me like the
hot gossip and she says the main hot
gossip right now is that women
are getting uh plugs for pubes to get
them back because they'd lazy them off
they lasered their pubes in their 20s
and now the guys are like we like pubes
and
i think that because you know men have
so much access to so many
shaved bots like anywhere i think by the
time you have someone that's actually
just like teasing you in some way it's
so much sexier yeah that's i like that
it's swinging back i think so there's
something just like more
sexual about it because i feel like
we've all gone so numb to what's
actually sexy
yeah you know see that i mean i think
what i try to put into my burlesque show
is everything's gotta have a little bit
of humor so i like i'm never overtly
sexual it's always to me i make
uh acts and scenes that i think are
funny you know so that always has that
and so it's not too serious or too
erotic it's like but i'll think of
something like oh i'm gonna ride a giant
lipstick like a bucking bronco because
it's it's funny it's like a fetish it's
so good thing but it still has something
that makes me laugh and if it makes me
laugh i mean i i don't it's more about
how i feel on stage really than than if
i think other people get are in on the
joke i mean sometimes they are but
sometimes they're not which is so like
it's such so mind-blowing for anything
like to feel sexy to feel strong
anything like if you don't feel it
they don't feel it right like it took me
so long like as a comedian to be like
you know i don't think this joke's that
funny it kills but like i don't like if
it doesn't make me laugh and now i have
a couple jokes in my new hour that's
like they do
well most of the time but they're kind
of five years ago i would cut it but i'm
like that one's for me like i gotta have
some fun up here yeah you don't know you
have to that's how i look at it too like
if they don't get it i don't really care
because you do it's just like yeah you
could be an actor and read the lines on
the page or you can be thinking
something while you're reading them
usually the opposite of what you're
saying totally and then it's magic so i
think the same thing with performance
and i'm sure with what you do too this
is disarming she's disarming it's very
disarming it's very intense really no
one's ever told me that you're
incredible you're incredibly disarming
the best way the best possible way okay
it's like i'm just fascinated by you
it's like when you and i'm i'm just
there's so many things i want to not do
but not to say and i'm trying to make it
so that my brain doesn't jump around i
have recently become obsessed with
fetishes because
the older i get the more i
like explore them obviously i'm on a
journey
uh but i'm fascinated because i'm just
i'm mostly fascinated by just like the
psychology of power in people and sex
and how sex is this way we can kind of
heal ourselves hurt ourselves if that's
what you're you know whatever what do
you have any intel on
uh foot fetish
i belie the two going theories i've
heard are that the feet look like dicks
look like little dicks
that babies when their mother was like
if their mother was like barefoot like
doing laundry or something or walking
around the house babies would try to
crawl towards their mother see their
toes and rub their hair interesting you
know and then this is how they do
your foot goes together like that right
right
i like your second two theories and from
what i know like i have a lot over the
years since i was 20 years old i've
known a lot of fetishists and interview
ask them a lot of questions
and i remember one of the most like
powerful foot fetishes people that i
ever knew that was really like really
basically he said i'd rather me rubbing
someone's foot is like better than sex
for me genuinely and i was like whoa
whoa well how did this start
and he said um
that he was in like grade school and the
girl in front of him used to take her
shoes off every day
and that was what triggered it for him
and i was like that's interesting but
that's not the same story for everyone
so it's different there's no one
universe i've heard other stories too
before but and then there's people that
like different things about feet so i
think
you know there's
you can't really say oh people that have
a foot fetish habit because of this
people that have a smoking fetish have
it because of this people that like to
be tramp you know someone has a
trampoline fetish with you if they saw
my feet they probably would not have a
fetish it's also specific to the feet i
feel like my favorite fetish that i had
heard of that i thought was really
amusing was this guy
um well actually i made a video and
every time i talk about this video
people go can i see that video going
nope saving it for a rainy day
um but this guy wrote a script about
like i would like it and i used to make
these custom videos for you know back in
the 90s and i just film it on the
camcorder with my friends or whatever
for people yeah they'd pay and i'd
they'd get their vhs so you started
cameo
yeah i mean i don't think i started it
but i used to do like little videos and
send it off to people in the same kind
of way you could order a betty page
video i basically followed the betty
page career and said okay she used to
make custom photos you know and videos
and they'd send them to these guys in a
plain paper package
so i would do things like that and
people would write me scripts and this
is you know it was they'd pay a lot yeah
so one of my favorites this guy wrote a
script about
me and my friend taking ballet class and
he was very specific pink tights with
seams up the back the ballet shoes
herron chignon with a hairnet you and
your friend are taking ballet class and
then you know she gets a little bit
annoyed with you for whatever reason and
um she puts a cream pie in your face
and then you put a cream pie in her face
it i've never i mean have you ever had a
pie in the face like for real real like
marie calendar
it's going to say we talk getting key
lime we i'm talking like a big thick
expensive pie
i'm every calendar student i spent my
first five years in la writing uh
fucking vagina jokes and marine
calendars um
so the ptsd is real uh you know what i
can't say ptsd can we not no
can you what it's my understanding you
can't it's you know you can't really say
ptsd anymore because people that have
real ptsd are offended by that yeah but
i have real ptsd
that's fine i know that's my argument
but that was i mean what's more dramatic
than
spending five years of marie calendars
on wilshire across from e
i feel like
i will i will happily uh get the letters
from that organization i did get in
trouble for saying spazz
i call myself a spaz really yeah i was
like i'm being such a spaz and like
that's like well that one i don't know
what is it it's just i don't mean the
spouses i don't know is it short for
something that's slang that's
spastic it is spastic like a bat it's
like if you say
[Applause]
or something but it's also like but
that's different skits if i say spazz
you're that's mean to spouses okay but
i'm being mean to myself and there's no
space and also a spasm is a real thing
right yes you know yeah and like i'm a
spaz okay i guess uh oh i'm gonna i
think i'm great i'm i'm not saying i'm a
terrible person i'm just saying i'm
spouse and i'm spazzer cool i'm gonna
let you keep spazz and ptsd
okay
okay okay but schizo i'm just cure we
have to ask i just want to know the
language you can't say that yeah i get
that you can say something
but so what if i
was actually i just love it she's in the
corner like on guard she's on guard i
need i need to hire somebody
kelly
my assistant over there she's never
she's going to advise me the wrong way
all the time
but i uh yes she basically just sits
here and um
makes it so that i don't get cancer
speaking of fetishes i heard you tell
this story one time in an interview that
i really thought was interesting about
this man
who his fetish was to watch really
well-dressed women litter yeah littering
in the forest
i have that script somewhere it's in my
storage somewhere it's one of my
favorites this should be a sh like a
like a doc like an hour
just like re-shoot like just shoot them
yeah just shoot like five or six of them
put put it on only fans my only fans
would live no i know but like i and i
really was like i want to do this one
and i don't know why i didn't do it but
yeah walking through the forest wearing
an amazing outfit and just littering
trash from my purse throwing out gum
like making a mess of the
he like and he also had one that was a
fantasy i was like i don't think that's
gonna happen dude but his his other
script was about wearing all these fur
coats and clubbing baby seals like and i
was like that's not cool but i was for a
second thinking maybe i can get like
some um like some stuffed animals you
know yeah that would be real i mean i
honestly i feel like john waters no not
text or mammals this is how you do this
you go like if you want me to get the
baby seals i need like 10 grand airfare
to get the seal to get the whole play it
through and then you got i'm sure
there's a taxidermy one somewhere at a
right but i wouldn't even want to club a
taxidermy seal it would break my heart i
wanna
yeah then you could spend stuffed
animals
donating to the harp seal
store
while we're on the topic of fetishes um
i have a question that we me and whitney
have discussed this there's this theory
that um that women don't have fetishes
they just mimic the fetishes of men i've
said that before and actually felt like
oh and the only reason i okay i'm not
gonna say they don't have fetishes
because it's like oh i have like the
things i like and king but
and and it is controversial to say that
because people don't like when you say
men have this and women have that but
like a real fetishist isn't it's you're
not a fetishist because you like to wear
a corset and you like to wear right like
you can like indulging in fetishism but
like a real fetish is like someone who
it's a replacement for sex for
like it's powerful it's strong you can't
it's
i've known many
for people who don't know before i was a
burlesque star i was a fetish model
probably the most famous one in the
world in the 90s
and i have met a lot of people and it's
like people that have a fetish it's like
very powerful so it's not just like oh i
like i have a oh i have a da da da
fetish yeah yeah no you don't know
just like a woman in pantyhose no it's
like this is my thing cunnilingus finish
that's not really it's something that's
not sexual yeah yeah i love that you
have a cunnilingus fetish but it's not
technically what it is i mean so
fascinated because uh like you know the
show uh what is the one my strange
addiction uh the guy that's in relation
with the car on my strange addiction and
it's like a full like that's a
replacement for sex and i just never
know because i was
running into the psychology of it but
then i worry a little bit if it comes
from trauma that i'm like making fun of
something that's coming from trauma
and but also
i'm sure there are women out there that
have it and i've never heard that they
don't at all i've always just heard it's
less less it happens less often but
where you always hear from
people that are true fetishes is like
it's mostly men that have that like
you know they get really turned on when
they wear you know women's underwear and
that's like their thing yeah
that's a whole thing yeah um uh i like
it
it's like an achilles heel i love like
when i've had boyfriends with a fetish
i'm just like
yeah every
such a fucking slam dunk you don't have
to guess you're like just put on the
bunny hat and we're outta here it's like
i got this there is something nice about
because i've never really been like i'm
just getting a point in my life where i
feel like i have like confidence like
sexually with some uh you know like i've
talked about sex a lot i'm very like
open about sex but i've i've never um
until now felt like comfortable enough
to be like i want that and i like this
and i don't like i'm just kind of like
too tired uh to comply with anything uh
anymore but
there is i'm swear i'm not trying to
make a joke but the fetish
this isn't a fetish i know but i did
date this guy that loved what i had this
is this i know this sounds bad
and i know you're going to think i'm
making a joke but he did
oh it started as like a joke and then it
just kind of became a thing where one
time i was like what i'm so scared i
know i can't wait to anticipation well i
was like we would like joke around a lot
and uh like funny sex is really fun to
me if you're like it was very toxic but
we would do like funny shit like
and um like he peed on me once in the
shower and i
but i we're in the shower and i could
like i was on the ground and he and i
could not stop laughing like we laughed
for like two days like i love it when
you like try crazy shit and it's either
awesome or you just like it's funny yeah
and so uh one time i didn't have my
makeup on and uh we were somewhere and i
don't know i just like felt and scared
and i just like put a paper bag over my
head
just and i just was like
and honestly it was like a joke at first
and then it was like not a joke and then
it was like a very consistent joke call
back of a joke and like all of a sudden
there's trips to trader joe's that
didn't need to be made
um
but i did find it very because you can
kind of just check out and i would like
to see that one acted out too when we're
making the horsepower
i'll do the paper bag for you i i the
letters we get let's compare the letters
we get emily gets asked by men to give
herself a wedgie
that's what she gets mostly she got
offered 7 500 and she didn't did you
take it she might not she called her dad
half of it to charity yes uh she called
her dad and said should i do this and he
said no which makes the whole thing even
hotter yeah exactly
but suddenly it's forbidden
you got you to get out of he's got you
right where he wants yeah you just keep
doing sexy things i was in hollywood
wedgies and like us magazine ones so
like one of my favorite tear sheets is
like pictures of people picking the
wedgie out and i remember it being like
hollywood wedgies and i was like
i was like i am in it although to be
fair mine was kind of cute i was just
like you know it wasn't as bad as it
could be
or your butt hollywood wedgies
dude that would i mean and the fact that
the same publications tried to be like
time's up it's like didn't you do a
segment just on wedge women yeah like
taking pictures of us pulling our
underwear over but the guests make it
like a like a section yeah like it's
like hollywood children at four years
old and wedgies uh a big one that i hear
is uh sitting on cakes oh i've done that
yeah that sounds so fun yeah so you know
what that's not what i could ask to do
with corporate gigs
well if you have to change that you have
to put it out into the human right i
really do i'm trying that's what getting
a pie in the face or sitting on a cake
or a pie is really liberating and you
will laugh like not that you'll pee your
pants yeah if you get it in your face
you will pee your pants i promise you
that's i mean i actually loved it so
much the first time i did it and i was
you know when you laugh like
so hard like like i'm on mushrooms type
of yes yes yes yes and you're laughing
so hard nothing comes out and your tears
go and you like piddle a little in your
underpants like that's what it's like
getting a real pie in the face when
you're you can't you're never ready for
it you're never ready even if you're
ready but you're not you're not ready
for your pie business called you're
never ready for it well i had a party a
new year's eve party once where i went
to the marie calendars
and i was i was getting a divorce and i
was really sad i didn't have any
furniture in my house i had nothing and
i thought you know what i'm gonna go buy
every pie at marie calendar sorry
and i bought oh there was people in line
behind me and i basically bought every
cream prize sorry and i had i had all my
friends like make trash bag couture
outfits and everyone paired up and took
a pie in the face from their friend
so it was one of my favorite parts i
love a theme party i okay i'm obsessed
with this
and
i'm sorry i just have so many questions
because we're doing this like tomorrow
you should i mean your house is perfect
for it right now because you're not
you don't have a bunch of velvet
furniture right now like we really gotta
get i'm trying to think what where do we
how do we feel about rhubarb what goes
in
you're never ready for a pie in the face
is just no truer words have ever been
spoken like a banana cream pie like a
big expensive banana cream some people
are going to get mad at me for wasting
food let's there's another like no we'll
eat it afterwards we're wasting we'll
eat it after yeah we give it to the
coyotes like a banana stuffed to your
cheek in the end we didn't we did a like
a a food fight for a video
and like when someone throws a cake in
your face it is just this like
it's like heals old invisible wounds yes
you laugh so hard you can take it
further and get a pie in the boobs too
like my friend when we did the ballet
video she pulled my leotard down and got
me right in the boobs and i was just
like beside myself with that styling
these have to happen again yeah well i
have the video and so how many did you
make total how much can i make on
youtube if i put this i mean quite a lot
like i feel like we can really get some
i need to get the ad thing figured out a
new thing because it's amazing it's
great yes it's an art film yeah i also
think they could just be like a
stand-alone sort of like you know tapes
like tapes you know of like things you
did in the past and then maybe
reboot them now it's all on vhs do new
ones now like there's a new save by the
bell like
yeah i kind of figured like all that
fetish stuff i did i would release it at
some point but i'm like it's too soon
yeah maybe i mean more fun when i'm like
you know 70 like
smoking a cigarette and i've never
smoked in my life just like thinking
it's
just but the like i always imagined
myself smoking the burning sign just
hitting you in the face
um and this is fascinating to me because
i think about
aging and you're like one of the
only people i talked to about who's like
i can't wait like i'm so and i can't
wait
to just age like wild and because i just
get more and more confident and
comfortable even more unedited what do
you think though about like i i recently
watched the hedy lamarr um documentary
again
obsessed with her and was it betty page
were they they both kind of just were
like we're gonna leave it how it was
yeah i mean she got really into plastic
surgery but again she was so smart that
she was telling them how to do it why i
still use those methods now but yeah
betty page kind of just went away
because she didn't know that she was she
she did run its course she was like
almost 30 and she was like oh that's
what you do in the 50s you're too old
for anything when you're 30. so she just
kind of like disappeared a little bit
and had some mental health issues but
she didn't know she was famous when they
when when they found her in their in
their mid 90s she had no idea she was a
cult figure i'm the opposite
i have no idea i'm not a girl i'm like
hey do you need a photo they're like
ma'am
that is so interesting to me because i
also feel like there's this you know for
whatever reason
a little bit of a
like a new take like fresh eyes on a lot
of women in history that were very
sexual like marilyn monroe is now like
like uh
everyone's therapist
you know things she's like there's like
i know like ceos of like banks that just
like put marilyn monroe quotes on their
instagram i'm like whoa like oh she
never said half of those things it's
like 100 no no she didn't say any of
those things to be honest like there's a
whole thing of like here's marilyn
monroe never said any of these things
but it's cool and it breaks my heart a
little bit because it's like it just is
you know when people are like yeah she i
don't know i just feel like we don't
have to pretend that she was like super
strong and together you know what i'm
saying like i'm sure she was in moments
but i feel like there's this new thing
like no she was fucking running point on
all those motherfuckers like i don't
know like you know just may west maybe
mae west absolutely so actually mae west
absolutely absolutely was can i ask you
as may west is my i have a storage unit
full of like mayweather stuff she's my
like original she's the
i mean she got paid more than any man in
hollywood more than the studio bosses
did you induce this to her and is this
just a uh a rumor because she was making
money we can't handle the fact that she
actually there were rumors that she was
a man and remembers that she was black
i know just just i mean yeah back then
but it's probably true that they'd made
those rumors that she was a man and she
wasn't right yeah and i'm just so
fucking there's plenty of proof because
she was older
yeah she made her first film at age 40.
and she was the biggest box office and
biggest sex symbol of the time at age
40. i mean she had a huge showbiz career
before that and vaudeville and you know
in writing plays but like who else in
that time made their first film at age
40 and became the biggest sex symbol of
her time wild yeah obsessed with her and
the highest paid yeah higher paid than
any male actor and was touring and was
responsible for a lot of i think uh
advances and being able to tour i don't
know yeah yeah it's just amazing don't
get me started on maywest let me what oh
you love i love yeah
why has there been no biopic
uh uh what i know about the biopic is
that bette midler was trying to get that
made for a long time
um
yeah it's been kind of floating around
for decades interesting yeah i don't
know what's tying it like who could do
it i think that natasha leon would be a
good man oh my god she would
i tell her that all the time and i think
that she's kind was kind of for i don't
know if there was yeah
she would be amazing
that would be incredible um yeah i'm
just i'm i'm just kind of fascinated by
like
looking back at the women we kind of
wronged because they were sexual like
like and nicole smith like yeah we like
the apologies we owe like i mean when
you just look back it's just sort of
you're like you know there's this
podcast called you're wrong about um
that i've been listening to that will
like uh deconstruct like how women were
treated by the media any women that were
like sex symbols like sort of the 70s to
now right and just sort of like how our
treatment of them does not hold up
interesting it's pretty fascinating yeah
listen yeah i'm like i'm obsessed with
nicole smith right now um may i ask you
about uh love i always ask
because i do not know the definition i
ask every guest that i respect what
their definition of love is how do you
know you're in it
um
i feel like i've been a lot i fall in
love easily i've been in love so many
times in my life
most i think a lot of people say oh i've
been in love like twice and i'm like
really i've been loved like 95 times
no but like really yes
right i've had a lot of long-term
relationships and i was totally in love
at the time you know i've a serial
monogamous since i was you know
since i was 14. my first boyfriend was
like five years between you know all in
high school wow so
um yeah i don't know i've been in love a
lot how do you know like how do you like
when do you say i love you to them oh i
mean i'm pretty i don't sling i love
yous around very easily
that's one thing yeah but that's also
like a a guard don't say it like a
greeting don't say it like you do i i
just think like i love yous and such
should be i like them in love letters i
like them when it has meaning or there's
actually feeling behind it not just like
a something we say to each other when we
get off the phone or whatever like yeah
i'm not really into that yeah what are
we doing are we having kids what's
happening oh no um i'm not i don't think
i am either i i just
you know i
i don't know i feel like i never got
around to it
madonna told me once not to let
motherhood pass me by that was the most
seriously i ever took it i was like oh
shoot
okay but i didn't i just felt like you
know i've been on this trajectory with
my work and always have been very
independent and
or been with somebody that i was just
like this would not be a good person to
have a child with even though i'm with
that person but not i don't want that
you know oh i'd be a single mother
basically and i sometimes i wish i had
had a baby when i was like in my 20s so
that i have this cool adult person no
maybe yeah but you know i just feel like
i made a bunch of decisions and maybe
they were right maybe they were wrong
maybe one day i'm gonna say shoot why
didn't i have kids i don't know it's
weird i feel like i might adopt at some
point but it is so weird that i have no
sense of urgency at all no i don't i
don't either especially in this climate
right now i feel a little bit like isn't
it probably more conscientious for some
people to bow out of having children i
feel that i get afraid that you know
with the
these airborne viruses what's the
next one and what what are they going to
be dealing with i don't know i have two
i have a lot of anxiety surrounding
like thinking about what i'm you know
what i'd be leaving behind like the
impact
and a lot of people i know are just
foregoing children because they're like
oh it's like not humane to bring a child
into the world but i'm like i love that
not humane yeah i could use that but
like all the smart people are going to
start stop having kids then all the dumb
people are just going to keep it's like
the people that sh that shouldn't are
the ones that are going to and the
people that you should that's a good
argument too yeah but but it's also like
it's just interesting to me because i am
i feel so full by my work like i
i don't feel anything missing but i also
i feel like i feel like adoption might
be good
i love kids babies just seem like
i don't know if i have the personality
for it
because you know what i'm saying
it's 24 7. and i'm just worried i'm
going to get dumber
they don't really
have much to offer like i will be
because i do feel like babies are meant
to be raised by many people you know
that's how we're sort of designed and
this whole just like you staring at a
fucking thing that
can't hold up its head like staring at a
fucking thing might be a person
i just like i don't understand why we
don't have the head fix the head like
why don't we have a like a shark tank
convention where the head stays up on
its own
do you know what i'm saying why like why
am i holding its head i have like it
feels a little wild well what is they
just can't put their heads up like it's
just we're the only
species that has to take this much care
of infants like most
animals are born fully walking and they
just leave
like this whole thing where you just
have to like stare at it for a year i
feel like that's gonna be that's gonna
be tricky for me it all seems like i
just don't have the energy for it
anymore that's the other thing now i
feel like i'm like at a point where all
i do is i'm in the airport and i see
these people they're kids and i'm like
it's just so much bending over it's just
so it's all having a kid is it's just
you're just bending over and carrying so
much stuff it's for short-term people
i think short people short shorter
people short short people i got worried
that that was going to sound like short
buzz and that's not what i now i'm in a
panic now everything i'm saying i just i
just feel like tall people
should get like a
free babysitter for the first year for
i'm this is my cause
yeah i mean i think but you would have
the cutest baby oh my god you that it
would be in like little suits
it would be blonde and it would be like
wait i don't see the resemblance at all
it would be the cute that oh i mean
i just i like the idea of them dressing
up in really cute outfits yeah you know
and actually one of my friends who's a
big artist he said
you have to have children the best thing
is you you tell them anything and they
believe you and you can dress them in
whatever you want and that was his thing
that
that's what his thing about telling me
why i have should have children was like
outfits and they'll believe anything you
say
that's also just a straight man if you
look like you
and uh that is really funny yeah i don't
know i just i see a lot of my
girlfriends that have big lives and
they're like
it seems like something has to give you
it's something's gotta give and then
they're wrought with guilt when they're
like okay i'll just have someone watch
them and then they're out with
guilt so it's just sort of this thing
where you're just like it's the only
thing you can't really undo huh right
and then i have that fear of like so say
you have like a baby with somebody
you're totally into that can all change
like oh
then you're suddenly like wait do i want
the man or do you want the baby
sometimes it's like it can turn it can
be all the hormones like i'm sure you've
read about some of this stuff about like
people that take the birth control pill
and it screws with your ability to pick
the right mate i feel like there's so
many things like that it really does so
it's like yes so if you are on birth
control your body thinks you're pregnant
right so essentially your body starts
seeking out men that are more quote
unquote alpha i know that word doesn't
mean anything anymore but more risk
takers bigger stronger which tend to be
like the guys like that wear axe body
spray and have chain wallets so if you
are on birth control they say if you get
engaged and you up to somebody you
should wait six take go off birth
control wait six months before you marry
the person because you might have just
been into them because you were smelling
their pheromones because you were
pregnant i was in like a five-year
relationship and it's like i'd go on and
off the pill and i'd just like hate his
scent when i was when i was on the pill
i was just like oh god i didn't like his
scent and then when i go off of it i'd
be like yeah oh wow and that's when i
was like okay this is real well because
it's like basically it's like so that's
someone that you wanted to sire your
baby but not necessarily be the father
afterwards uh because
uh someone that's good at um getting you
pregnant or is not always the good the
guy that you want hanging around they
just need to move on and fuck more
people and then you want more of like a
quote-unquote beta to be around so
that's wild yeah that's fascinating yeah
i've been on so many birth controls out
of at this point i don't even know but i
think it was more my personality that it
didn't work out um but that's a really
fascinating thing about the birth
control um
okay because there yeah i guess yeah i
don't know you're just really making me
feel better about this i don't i'm not
saying i mean i just it's it's really
just i chose my
career yeah because i love show business
and i love like i got on a you know when
you get at least i didn't never expected
first of all to be
known for what i was doing it was just a
hobby it was just fun and so when i
started having these like victories and
i was like wow that was pretty amazing
that i'm doing this i couldn't stop you
know and i just felt like i got to keep
going see how far i can take this you
know to me it was crazy to be famous for
being a burlesque dancer in you know
this era having really crazy fun
i kind of just felt like well i gotta
keep on this
what do you do for entertainment if you
if you want to go see entertainment what
do you do um
i mean
i like to go to like music festivals and
show like concerts and things like that
or i like to entertain at home nice yeah
what do you do to your skin let's just
get to it my skin um i mean like i said
i don't smoke cigarettes
i haven't done anything yet i was
thinking about trying some lasers oh i
don't know i just mean like is there a
oh like no sunscreen you know yeah you
just do sunscreen and what's your
ancestry
i'm like just like a european style mutt
you know american style like scotland
england wow tiny bit of armenian like
116 like my grandmother was adopted and
her mom had an affair with an armenian
man and that's how she was born
it's like a tiny tiny bit wow because
sometimes you look italian to me it's
just the hair dye i know but my eyebrows
are dyed i mean it's like does anyone
has anyone's face ever looked like this
not that i know of like
it's like a it's just wild
wow okay thanks but like what do you do
to your i mean i looked up your things
on amazon you use
got my beauty book there yes yes okay so
we're gonna go all through this
um uh we're gonna do some makeup
tutorials on another episode with these
but also like is there any like yours
like a skin like mine are always um
weird i sleep with noise canceling
headphones so that my skin at night
never touches my pillow yeah i taught
myself to sleep on my back too but no
headphones is a good idea so that you
put all your product on and your oil and
you go to bed and it doesn't just rub
right off on your pillow two seconds
later i guess i'm afraid of having like
because i have i'm a light sleeper and i
can hear everything oh me too so i'm
afraid if i wear headphones i'm not
gonna hear like somebody like break into
my house or whatever i won't have time
to get my gun right right right right
how far is your gun from here oh it's
right there okay that's right so
we're doing
we have or my my bow and arrow i was
gonna say how are your fencing yeah i do
have a fencing i bet i bet who was it oh
it was ellen i was in ellen's office
once and there was this giant you know
when someone just has everything and it
was this giant fencing out thing and i
was like oh what's this from and i was
like no it's just like it's just an
amazing thing i decided to take up
fencing once because i thought what
that's a great way to meet guys right
and then i realize you have one leg
bigger than the other because you can't
and i took a few lessons and and he's
like oh yeah you always have one your
right leg always be bigger i go you
can't switch he's no you can't switch so
then i give it up don't we always have
one
like a leg that's bigger than the other
i have one boob that's bigger than the
other it's true but like i don't want to
have one big one massive look at olympic
like fencers i mean i'm never gonna be
olympic fencer but you know what i'm
saying it's like i just thought like oh
and then i gotta work out the other leg
you know this is a this is a a major
problem with fencing that i've never
thought of before it's a sexy sport but
yeah the big thighs and look i'm wearing
a fencing outfit basically right now
my shirt is do do you exercise like do
you yeah um i do pilates and i do like
crossfit training like weight training
jesus because i like that and i also
thought that's another great way to meet
guys like oh yeah go to the crossfit gym
yeah go hang out with them although i
don't know
i don't run around the building and all
that stuff i you know have a private you
know take a one-on-one
training and you know he'll say
something like you almost did crossfit
today
that was almost
because i get like oh i have to do this
again like three times i have to run
through these yeah i'm not really that
into it but it's good for the butt and
all that that's exceeded my butt that's
the thing how do you how how is your
butt so
it's i mean like it's not it's body body
shape you know like it's like i'm good
at making moving my body in a way that
looks
you know yeah i mean when i'm performing
i'm very like okay my hips go that way
my rib cage goes that way i'm like in
high heels it's you know yeah you don't
catch me flat-footed you don't want to
see that you know
i mean
like i know what you're saying i see
okay so yeah manipulation of the yeah
right holding holding myself when i'm
taking my clothes off on stage i'm
holding myself in a certain way do you
ever do any like little like i do these
bands whenever i'm on a plane yeah okay
that are just like these exercise bands
to get the outside of my butt yeah just
always doing kegels uh i mean obviously
squats and lunges and all that stuff and
this like thing where you put the you
put the band around your knees and
you're yeah yeah yeah like the little
monster walk thing you go back and forth
and one where you my new one is that uh
it's uh you can be standing and put a
weight in between the back of your knee
like ten and then lift up back you know
there's also this machine that i kind of
like that's called the m sculpt and they
put it in your butt on it's like it i
you've done it it's so funny i can't
tell if it works i can't tell if it
works but i love it because i think it's
hilarious i mean it's a pretty expensive
laugh but it's like you know because
it's really
it's like putting like a
it
it's like uh i don't know how to
describe it but i always feel like
there's a thing like a longinus
heart with those two irons it's like two
things they attach it to your butt or
they can do it i did it in my legs i did
my stomach you did it yeah so you know
what i mean what about the tapping is
what i really laugh about when it starts
going down and tapping up yeah
it's supposedly equal to like a hundred
squats or without even 20 030 minutes
but like i was very sore the next day
like my
my abs were my butt so i was like this
must be something but i don't know
benton's convinced it to be they should
send they should send us the machine and
let us try it yeah just i i actually was
thinking about getting one for the house
please do i will be here for all this
time this is how i'm gonna we'll find
out if we're friends guys
i'll go in on it i'm gonna be very
popular i know i i know a lot of big
celebrities have them in there i know
it's so expensive well we can talk about
a paid partnership
are you picky about what you do paid
partnerships with yeah i don't really
but i actually had an idea for them and
i pitched them on and they liked it but
i just kind of like i'm very weird i
don't like to advertise things like i
feel like then i get worried that it's
not the right message because i like to
put that thing on my ass like i think
it's f it's part of my job right like
like working out is my job to be strong
more than be what it looks like i need
to be strong
i always just get worried like other
people will be like why are you selling
that people get so mad about what you're
selling to them or what's offensive to
them you know
hmm we need to block more words on your
instagram i know right
but it's also those are just the people
that were already grumpy or yeah i just
think like oh i love to sell things that
i actually like yeah like sorry i hope
you find a job one day that lets you
sell what you love yeah yeah i'm so and
i'm so in this place where i don't it's
so interesting to hear you uh talk about
feedback because to me you've just been
like so
consistently
dignified and uh have made classy
choices and maybe that's why people just
are like yeah i mean i turned down a lot
of stuff like i think i was offered like
a
some jeans ad years ago for tons of
money and i said no way because i don't
wear jeans you know
like i don't like things that are
inauthentic or i got offered like the
jimmy choo campaign i said no because
kristen christian louboutin is my close
friend you know i was like i do that all
the time i don't like to really
put my name to things that i'm like oh i
don't think it's right unless you're
going to own them unless it's your
makeup yeah i like it
yeah i think it's
smarter to make your own stuff i mean
i don't know what's smarter i don't know
i'm not like a business genius was there
anything that you're like i wish i'd
done that i wish i had done like i
should have done it i should have said
yes
should have invested in liquid death
yeah less than that lashify yeah my
lashes well i do love my lash of eye
collaboration that's one of those things
people are like you're really pushing
those lashes i go because it changed my
life that's why because i love lash
extension can you edit the book to
include it i'm going to edit the beauty
book to include it thanks over there
more about me he's like hey don't forget
to mention no but like i was scrolling
through instagram and i found like one
of these lash ads and i was like i'm
going to try that and then cut two and
cali wears left we were obsessed with it
it's like doing your own lash extensions
at home and they stay on for like you
know some people wear them for like two
weeks i only wear them for like three
days wow wow because i like to wash my
eyeballs you know
um but yeah
so i like things that i'm really into
and so i basically was doing this
i got aligned with them in a really
natural way i bought the kids right and
they do a class with you on zoom with
one of their experts if you want to have
a lesson so i get on there and this
girl's like oh my god you're dead of
aunties and i was like yeah she goes you
should meet our founder maybe
and then next thing you know i was like
talking to the i was at her place and i
was in like lashley
she offered me to be like you know as an
ambassador i was like yeah because i
love this product so you know so that's
the thing anytime it's like if if you're
doing something authentic when people
are you're just shilling this thing it's
like no you asked me what i do to my
skin and now i'm telling you right and
like you know
i bought it i'm a customer that just
suddenly went oh cool i get free lashes
yeah count me yeah exactly like it's
like it's yeah it's so it's so wild
though then to know though i feel like
when you're like do i do it on my own do
i work aligned with this company you
know what i mean it's like you have to
like to trust everything is like i get
overwhelmed and feel spread too thin
when i do too many things on my own you
know you can be like oh i'm going to
make my own skincare i'm going to make
my own perfume and make my own lipstick
and then suddenly you're like but who's
going to manage this
it has to be all i hear is the human
resources department when you say that
oh
we now are taking a break from the
velvety
dida von teese who is really inspiring
me to
be very careful with what i put in my
body
i mean she is embalmed and i'm gonna
stop shopping at costco for underwear
no you're not
and i'm going to keep doing everything i
do
that obviously not no one ever ever
thought that you would uh because i've
been a geeta fan for a long time so i
know where confidence come from no i'm
just saying her how does she look like i
mean she is
i i'm just looking at her and i'm like i
need to take better care of myself i
need to drink more water and i need to
stop eating trash uh and i have no
excuse anymore i know i'm looking at her
and i'm like what did i do in my past
life to deserve this
i mean it would have rather been a
cockroach does she only like eat like
fish oil like i just feel like a
porcelain doll i feel like she's hella
fresh we've talked about hella fresh
before and i need you to count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable that's why it's america's
number one meal kit i love hello fresh
i've been using it for
two years now and i sometimes have hello
fresh dinner parties where i make like
two or three different meals i didn't
get an invite to that
like you would have came
um not the point
we'd like to definitely
if i knew hellofresh was there yeah i
recently made the little sweet little
little spicy chicken yeah that's my
nickname for you actually how did you
know that i know they actually named it
after me
sometimes sweet sometimes zucchini
tomato ricotta like flatbread my
nickname
there's no it's white bread
white flavor there's like a texas like
mac and cheese
it's all so easy and so delicious and it
only takes like
30 minutes hellofresh offers over 25
recipes to choose from each week from
vegetarian meals to craft burgers and
extra special gourmet options there's
something for everyone to enjoy with all
recipes designed and tested by
professional chefs and nutritional
experts to ensure deliciousness and
simplicity hellos fresh is hello
freshest fresh ingredients are sourced
directly from growers and delivered from
the farm to your front door in under a
week contact free of course go to
hellofresh.com good for you 12 and use
code good for you 12 for 12 free meals
including free shipping that's
hellofresh.com good for you 12 and use
code good for you 12 for 12 free meals
including free shipping america's number
one meal kit wowza oh speaking of wowza
i'm gonna come wows y'all uh in san
diego on january 7th um january 8th i'll
be in salt lake city uh kingsbury hall
now i feel like dia de vantis has been
talking about what she does at her shows
and no one's going to want to come see
me just do stand up not in your
underwear not in a champagne glass you
think you're you take your hold off
quite often if you're shooting i am way
more naked at my shows than deena is
your parents keep splitting yeah they
keep splitting open which everybody
thinks is like something i'm like yeah
like pants and everybody those cartoon
eyes like whoo
on the same no it's hubba hubba
hopefully uh so my pants keep splitting
at my shows i don't know if that's a
deterrent or an attraction at an
attraction oh you keep doing those
cartwheels um
anyway so come see my cottage cheesy
butt on january 28th nashville tennessee
polk theater january 29th durham north
carolina cannot wait to come to the
south charlotte north carolina
charleston south carolina wilmington
delaware delaware down ashore we're
going well that's not down to shore
that's atlantic city delaware where i
made most of my mistakes as a child at
in ocean city bethany dewey uh
you all you're a vehicle bitch we got it
you're right bethany bitch i was made
most of my childhood mistake that chuck
e cheese one times chucky cheese pushed
me down and kicked me did you know that
the actual
yeah the rat in the costume and honestly
i i i i feel i my brain goes what did
you do to that i asked him but he was a
real rat or not see you know what that's
never been to chuck e cheese deeda wait
i would love that though now we are back
to dita vontis
meet my fetish oh my god you are going
to meet new and improved oh my god
cleavage is killing it
so her body is is not here i can move
her over more she's like real doll world
so this is she's she is a real dog so
this is a robot that was uh
dead in the eyes though made for my
small the headshooter had to look
exactly like me yeah so that's why we
did it
um and so we made this for my last
special and it was a
basically we had to change her face we
had to redo it because i was getting
older and she needed more like crow's
feet and stuff she was starting to look
younger than me and it was oh my god it
is amazing what is your
okay let's see if we can get her to hold
on i can get her to kind of i don't know
she has new hardware
wow
she needs some oil in her eyes or
something yeah it's a little dry because
she needs your last sound i think she i
know her i love it
what was the decision they had to like
just cut this part off and say
because i mean look i think it's kind of
progressive that someone only wants the
head of a woman it's also very heavy
that's probably why they're so she has a
body but to carry it around is very
cumbersome it is right around so you
carry her around
it all over new york ben had to carry
her at one point and does she have some
wigs she does have some wigs we cut it
we'd oh that's right uh fuck at the
beginning of quarantine but also my
hair's been a different color so much
that we'll probably just get her so i
figured you need like 12 wigs is it so
weird
see i love it no but i love it i love
that you love it a lot of people get rid
of i'm into it weirded out by it really
into it you know why we are so uh uh
weirded out by looking at her ears and
then looking at your ear like i'm really
like oh yeah because i had this ear bit
like bitten off by a dog so it's got the
same like scar
she did come back last time the problem
is that straight guys are making these
we need to get more women making them
because uh i was like can you make some
like eyebrows for her you know
and they had just cut two parts of the
wig and it was just oh yeah
it looked like it was like colonel
sanders it looks like it looked it was
like growing it was two mustaches on the
top of her so we went back to this so
because you said that about birth
control i feel like you would i probably
already know this but that part of the
reason people are so freaked out about
uh robots or dolls that look human
anything that that looks human but
doesn't move like a human it's called
pathogen avoidance it's how we evolve to
like not fuck things that are sick or
dead
wild wow that's why like you know when
you see a guy that like sees a robot or
like a doll
and they're like it's like why are you
so scared of this like it's a toy it's
like you know less less dangerous than
the car you driving every day but it's
like a very deep uh primordial way to
get them to not fuck corpses that's how
gnarly we are as a species
like we had to evolve to be repelled by
dead corpses so that we wouldn't fuck
them well i can't really get her to talk
maybe she's just being shy because she
has all these new um expressions now
that i kind of want to show you i'm
upset like i just love how i love a
feeling
as a performer that when people feel odd
like that odd
i'm super into her you know what i mean
it's like it's just like a i brought out
on stage once i was like this would be a
disaster but the reaction from people
like some people were scared some people
were grossed out some were like i just
love that feeling you know what i mean
yeah i was just thinking i wonder if i
could get one and she could do the meet
and greets and that's honestly because
that's the next thing
that's the next thing and you don't have
time
why don't you yeah i'm just saying yeah
i know we have a lot to do with the show
i like meeting my fans i don't want to
make it out of that i really love it but
that this way they can just take
pictures you know it should just be
honestly this thing is now so much more
famous than i am people come to me and
greets and like is bear claw here like
they want this at that her name what's
her name oh there she is
did she go
hi dita
so uh i i just find this fascinating
because i'm just sort of thinking about
like what's the next thing i want to do
like what's the next way i want to like
make people feel
and um uh like is there anything that
you are like the white whale of
something you want to do like this was a
big one for me like where you're like
okay
next tour like i've been wanting to do
this thing we haven't done it for
whatever reason covid
you know we've been so like as artists
like had so little options for the past
couple years is there anything that
you're just like
i don't know this thing with the horse
flying in right i mean i
yeah i mean i always just want when
before the pandemic i had invested in
this curtain which i was really excited
about and then it got to the tour and it
didn't work but it's called a
venetian curtain okay
and it's basically looks like a straight
curtain and then it does choreography
like it it's a motor that can like turn
it into i hope it's not this motor
because uh you'll fall right now like
it's is really complicated and i was so
excited about that toy
um but i think we're going to get it
fixed for my european tour which i'm
very so that's what i'm really excited
about is this thing that i bought that
didn't work for the whole tour and now
i'm like okay that's been the thing
because i want it to do choreography
you know like it can flutter when i walk
by or
a door part of it can open i can walk
through it and you know or two sides can
open and it can
do things it's kind of psychedelic
it huh it's a little louder i know
that's the lighting at your show is
really incredible oh thanks well that's
important
how many days do you have to rehearse in
a venue
to feel like i everything's great i mean
i try to i rehearse like before like all
the like dancing stuff before and then
we usually only get like one or two days
in the venue to set up like for my new
year's eve show we will be in there for
the day before and the day of and that's
gonna be there to help if you need
anything i'm
okay guys
set this up yeah you're gonna shoot it
for something
um it's kind of complicated i'd like to
shoot it for something but it's kind of
hard to shoot in these seated theaters
without like a big production right and
i don't you know it's hard it's kind of
hard to get people on board with
burlesque in a lot of ways like tv and
stuff like that they don't really get it
still
one of my first jobs i ever did was uh
it was called live nude comedy it was on
showtime it was a burlesque show and uh
wait why didn't you call me comedy i
mean because you were not even they
asked you to host it like you they you
were it was it was a very
last minute i wrote about my book carmen
elektra ended up posting it and then she
wanted me to write a bunch of jokes
and they hurt her feelings so then it
was elizabeth it was like two comedians
two i mean we should do it again two
comedians and two burlesque dancers
because it's like let's do it again
unless you have an hour you really do
have to do it you know with a bunch of
people what do you do with like one
great five-minute piece i guess with
instagram now you can like post it but
it was it was actually really fun and
really cool and really like
i love that reaction like yeah like that
thing got like was pulled like they
pulled that off yeah i love when people
have their minds changed yes burlesque
what it is you know that's what i'm
always looking for in my show is like
somebody i had a like list yesterday to
one of my friends who's a dancer and
creative director i was like here's what
i'm looking for i feel like i have my my
my list of people i'm trying to cast and
one of them at the top of it is like i
really want like
a silver fox like this
comes out and like
you know he looks like you know gray
silver fox kind of guy and then he does
like a strip tease and opens his shirt
and is like unbelievable underneath it
just like you know and getting getting
rid of the aegis thing you know i want
my show has always been like naturally
diverse and inclusive because like i
found those are the the acts that were
the most exciting to watch absolutely
well if you like uh changing people's
minds about stuff and having inclusive i
do have one botched boob and one good
one i like it i feel like that's a good
let's go you know what i mean we need
right
i do have one fake tit where you can see
the puckering plastic on the side so
there's probably someone out there who's
into that yes benton do you have any
questions for dita
or do you have any questions
i was like i already know everything i
don't have any questions
i do
let's see if she knows everything shows
let's see if she knows everything so
many shows the last one i went to it was
like you and catherine delish
it was so i mean it was just incredible
every time i love the um
the uh like the aphrodite
oh the
clamshell thing with the
camera
the powder puff was one of my favorites
how do you think of those like how do
you come up with like i mean it's me and
catherine like just
my katherine delish is like she makes
all the most extravagant costumes and we
would come up with things and a lot of
it would be like let's you know come up
with these outrageous ideas and then see
what works and what doesn't work
you know like things that are
far-fetched sometimes and then do you
film yourself doing it so you can watch
it we just like come up with ideas and
be like it starts with sometimes the
swarovski crystal color like we should
do costume in this color yeah but yeah
like just kind of things that are a
little funny and silly and you know
yeah has there been anything lately
where you're like uh in this climate
let's just skip it
yeah there's things first of all there's
definitely things like i did in the
beginning of my career i'm not doing now
for a number of reasons yeah i grew up
like even the powder compact show i feel
a little bit like i used to you know
come out of that in the you know early
2000s and bounce around and like
on point and i feel a little bit like i
don't think i can dance on point anymore
and i feel a little bit like a little
you know like it just seems a little bit
too girlish and i want to be more
womanly yeah you know that's cool i just
so there's things like that yeah you
know
those costumes have to be so heavy
that's what i always think about the
time like these the sounds have to be
like two minutes hilarious as you know
the cowboys show that's one of my
favorites
so it's all swarovski crystal it weighs
like literally like 24 pounds it's super
maybe you do do crush okay just yeah and
i was on when i was on dancing with the
stars they're like do you think do you
first of all they said do you have this
outfit with you that you could wear it
and i was like
first of all why am i gonna have that
outfit it travels in its own like road
case first of all and it weighs a ton
and has to be insured and then secondly
though like i can't do these dances and
that you know
it's ways no they yeah they were trying
to weigh you down they knew that that
you were they were fucked they were yeah
they were they were trying to just weigh
her down yeah you were the heaviest guys
i love you on dancing with the stars on
instagram with your translator being
like i need more rhinestones more
rhinestones
you just pluto straws or something like
that i can't remember was that your
first dancing with the stars yeah
and and parents yeah
they were trying to get rid of me the
whole time like so much sabotage and
like you know
just uh yeah they finally the la when i
went home
i went home like fifth
and they came up with a rule they're
like i know this one will get her
um because i was doing well you know i i
never knew i could dance like that and i
was having so much fun and there you
know but it i was costing them more than
anybody to keep there
you know they're like yeah and i was a
pain and they asked for them in so many
ways like you know with their coveted
protocols and everything i was
constantly like hey
yeah yeah yeah challenging them on
things yeah but um this american woman i
mean i had kovid when i first got there
too and they didn't test me or anything
and i was like can i get a covet test i
feel a little like hot i feel like do
you think you don't know you're fine
i think i must have i had delta variant
even though i'm vaccinated yeah and um
and i wasn't vaccinated that long ago
either and i on the plane i was like oh
it feels kind of hot and my throat feels
dry no and then when i landed i was like
are you guys going to test me before i
step on set and they didn't you know and
finally i was i went and got the
physicals went to the cardiologist i
said do you think i should get a covet
test it felt kind of hot but it was like
90 degrees in paris at the time and no
air conditioning anywhere so i thought
like oh it's that or maybe it's a
menopause i don't know
and i just
was like okay and then finally i went
and got a test and then there's nothing
like some cheese eat this mold yeah
that's how we stay healthy
snails
eat these snails and have some moles but
you do do so many very glamorous things
like i want to know what's like some
what's some like fashion show
underground glamour teeth like
underground
okay glamour
like do you mean like
like
these people they must be the most
glamorous people just talking the most
glamorous trash and i want to know
glamorous oh like okay so the hot glass
like the hot louboutin what's this is
this my car oh these are the playing
cards i haven't seen those in a long
time there they are
you ha that was yours you have like a
collecting
like just a little bit i have signed
every poster booklet i know every time
benjamin sends me like a photo of
something in his uh like in your place
like a dog or something there's just
like pictures of you in the background
yeah my friend i haven't had artwork
it's what i have your mac lipstick in a
case because i worked for mac during
that oh okay now i know where to send my
like things i'm just like you're gonna
get like envelopes of like here's my
stockings i wore in that show
here's one random pasty here's like oh
these shoes i broke this heel on the
shoe it's yours
showing up in bentley's everyday because
he's selling it all on ebay it's like
wait a second um uh i did you ever do
any weird jobs like to make money before
you really started besides the fetish
videos somebody told you about i mean is
that not weird enough to me that's just
great fan interaction uh i don't know i
mean my first job was working in a
lingerie store and that's why i have my
own lingerie line and all that stuff now
but and it started my whole career
[Applause]
because okay so i've ordered a lot of
your lingerie i have questions because
yes i didn't know what size we were
trying to google your size we were like
trying to figure it out thank you so
much
uh i emily was like um what's your
lingerie size it was like there's no way
this is gonna go well she's
like like 34c top and then she's like
bottom
small medium large like which like which
one is the what's most flattering yeah
like what is the compliment um but no i
want to talk to you because i've never
had a bra fit me okay well what is the
what is it you worked in the lingerie
store you're the queen of all
okay so this i hope it fits this if it
doesn't we'll get you another size i am
obsessed with this type of the lingerie
that you do it is so i mean i'm also
binging madman right now it is so much
sexier to me than anything garter
okay look these i always end up getting
carpal tunnel trying to get these yes
little guys on
but and the colors that you use uh look
at this forest green have you ever in
your life i'm taking on new lovers so
this is very exciting but okay so so
is the is the wire supposed to go
it should be right underneath and it
should like the sternum area should sit
flat you know right right against
because i i recently was told that my
because my boobs are fake obviously i've
talked about this a lot but that um
because they were different sizes and
i'd even amount etc etc uh i
i heard that okay so i'm a c but i they
told me i'm a d because like why i feel
like you might be bigger than this like
we need to get you a bigger size i don't
know because my boob is just like very
wide sorry this is just what we do i'm
auditioning for your show because
sometimes underwire goes like here you
know no you don't want that but i feel
like this is going to feel like also
they're you know these are going to be
too small for you but we'll get the
right size i'll bring i'll come back and
i'll bring like an abundance of sizes
and we'll just figure out how it works
what's that fine
you know i bought the leopard one just
to support you you did
um and then let me ask you you put your
um lingerie in the freezer fridge i mean
that was just like a little homage to
marilyn monroe and the seven year rich
oh that's right yeah i was just like you
know what can i do like it's to be
stupid in her architecture and i also
was like how am i going to plug my
lingerie line on mtv
oh yeah that's right it was like what do
i do oh i need those in the fridge
because they do the what's in your face
you are such a genius business woman no
i'm just trying to make things happen i
know but you do it in just the most
elegant way you're just so elegant
dude i'm saying i mean so are we over
here but i'm just trying to be subtle i
don't like the big cell like i can never
imagine myself going on like social
media like hey guys so this is my bra
you should really buy it because it's
something like i can't do that kind of
stuff so i have to like be
subtle and like if you like things like
this
but that is like such a part of it it's
like i don't you'll it's the art of
seduction one-on-one you're not trying
to do it on purpose but it's like you
come i'll let you come to me that's how
that's how much i believe in what i'm
doing is that i don't need to chase is
this true whatever you chase yourself
like i don't think everyone needs to
wear
this kind of lingerie to be sexy it's
like whatever floats your boat you know
whatever i like to switch but like this
is what i like maybe you like it too i
don't know i'm obsessed and look at the
back look how gorgeous um and these
colors just make me like angry they make
me this is this is like the fuchsia that
i've been so obsessed with for so long i
love it with red for some reason and
then okay so do you just really quick
because underwear i'm speaking mostly to
emily right now i do em at appointment
life where the underwear you're wearing
i think
changes your day
yes i mean your personality your
confidence everything
it's like
something about how it makes you feel
but also like the size if the size is
right and you don't have to pull them
out do you be in hollywood wedgies all
day
like i get like i can't wear a career
i'll get like i cannot with these
underwear today you know if they're too
big it's bad if they're too small i just
mean like it's like i i to me it's just
like a little bit of like i hate when
people say life hack but it's like kind
of a thing that i underestimated or
didn't i hadn't really a tool i hadn't
really employed until i got older and
the pandemic happened and i was like
pajamas all day and like these like you
know full butt underwear and i wasn't
getting anything done and i was like my
self-esteem was saying and then i was
like because i'm not fucking pulling it
together you know and the way what you
put under you're allowed to be
comfortable but like putting on a bra
like having it under it makes me feel
like i have a secret it makes me feel
like i
respect myself i'm kind of like yeah i'm
not just phoning it in under there
emily gets her underwear from boston
it's fun
i i've always loved even when i was you
know like working in the lingerie store
when i was 15 you know i was just loved
having matching lingerie and matching it
to my clothes it was kind of like this
fun little thing that i did just for me
and it also it's like a little ritual
it's like a morning ritual to be okay
i'm doing this today i'm gonna have that
like it's just like a little form of
self-care
and uh you know because i know that like
throughout the day if i like go pee and
i look down i've got my like ratty like
thong that's just like hanging by a
thread i'm just like i hate it makes me
just like bums myself out and like it's
great like i feel like having worked in
lingerie a lot of my life
you know it used to be like you come in
people would come in and shop for their
everyday lingerie which was like plain
stuff and then the fancy lingerie for
sex or whatever but
everything's changed now like things fit
well and everyone's like my line is very
like it has to feel good fit right
that's the whole thing like everything
wearable and usable and
you don't need to buy the well i just
have a little bit of a what your the bra
that you have on is very serious okay
the bra that i have on now as annie
letterman says did you get that at the
holocaust museum
now i do
i do tend to wear
not underwire because i feel like they
never fit
because i always say that i might
secretly be a d okay most people most
women don't wear their right bra size
right right i i would call you maybe
like a d a double d even
because also there's a whole like vanity
sizing thing yeah and you know every
brand it's like where they make the bro
the cup sizes
smaller than they really are because
people get excited about buying oh i'm a
double d
going home be like i bought a double d
bra today and look it fits perfectly is
it too
it's not bad but a little small it's a
little small but it's not yeah but it's
making my boobs kind of pointy which is
kind of cute yeah
right good color on you right this is
such a great i mean i mean it's pretty
good wow it's pretty good now if only i
had her face we'd be really busy
do you need a lingerie model just
curious yeah i do it's like you have to
modify the bras to be like only oh she's
the best quarter boobs oh she does you
mean there's more to her whole body well
she has we i was in a foo fighters movie
and they
needed to saw me in half and then covet
happened so we like couldn't get this
done double and i was like i do have a
robot
just like me and they were like can we
saw it in half i was like sure i mean
it's actually the least disgusting thing
that's probably going to happen to her
and then so now we're getting her a new
body okay because it's and also the sex
robot bodies they're they're not quite
um you know they're not machines yet but
the biggest problem is that they're kind
of heavy but i don't want it to just be
like a skinny thing that doesn't look
like my actual body so uh they're making
one that's like their thighs her thighs
touch and whatever it's gonna make it
harder to put clothes on her butt um but
the problem is they're so heavy that
they have to keep them kind of skinny
because when i first went to the robot
factory i was like why are they also
skinny this is not what all women look
like and they were like our biggest
complaint actually from buyers which is
a lot of men that are handicapped it's
also a lot of gay people that get a
robot to try out first so they're not
feel like they're not gonna get rejected
and then i'm sure there's a lot of
creeps too but uh one of their biggest
complaints was that the uh bodies aren't
bigger and they said that's why they
don't sell as many robots because
they're so big and heavy right yeah yeah
and basically like you know when men are
requesting bigger bodies but they are
just too heavy at this point which is
pretty wild and then their other number
one the number one most requested nipple
was large and dark and as big as the
dark
wow
right shoot
let's head down the tattoo parlor but
that's the kind of man like i think
that's a that's uh because when you
breastfeed your nipples get darker right
that's what i've heard i feel like
that's that what that is don't you think
maybe
i don't know i'm obsessed with this i
feel very like adult in this bra i feel
fantastic but it's like looks fantastic
for like a photo shoot right but like to
really wear it but it's so comfortable
though to me you'd think i need a bigger
size i would say wider but because i it
fee it feels so comfortable and nothing
is i always like most underwire brushes
you know i'm like full steve irwin i
feel like i'm just getting stabbed by
a piece of metal i just feel like a
little bit bigger in the cup and then do
you wash your bras hand wash and hang
i throw them in the washer on hand wash
cycle
in a bag yeah um
but you know with this and i and i put
them on the air dry but you know i also
have an unlimited supply of lingerie i
have to wear the new
styles every season so it's like i'm not
trying to
you know keep my bras looking i've i
have a lot of lingerie because i like to
test everything yeah whatever you have
to do you have to do you go to other
country like when you're in paris like
go to lingerie stores and like
um i only what i like is buying like
slips and like things to sleep in you
know robes and things that i don't
really make right now right yeah are you
gonna do that
i have before and i'm trying to go back
can we do house coats please yeah i mean
i love like just a loungewear that you
can wear also out like a beautiful
pajama that you can also wear out if you
want yeah yeah yeah i'm just i'm always
pushing but you know i'm i have to like
tell them they have to do it and then
they get like oh no that's not gonna
work in the marketplace that doesn't
have hanger appeal that's my least
favorite thing how that doesn't have a
hanger appeal i'm like really well how
does this have hanger appeal yeah i
guess it does but i mean i don't want to
find it but there's it's it's not hanger
appeal anymore isn't it just instagram
appeal or visual that's what i say
you'll see it on someone's water stuff
and they're going to get it in a bag and
they're going to put it on and right
that's like
it's amazing gorgeous like a house coat
i mean she's amazing my friend catherine
delish has all those like extravagant
robes and it always makes me think of it
as a fedora duncan
she has a lot of stuff yeah is it was it
duncan is that who got it was a scarf
yeah okay like a scarf but not a
dressing gown okay it's okay
i always just think of my brain just
like that that's my excuse for not being
glamorous i guess i just have to dress
like this because this is excuse for not
being glamorous you might kill yourself
okay i may have yeah
okay taking a quick break from the
heavenly dita fontisse and look i know i
know i'm just gonna say the elephant in
the living room i know that i seem very
reserved quiet shy but i am willing to
push that to the side just for a moment
to talk to you about something
very important
sex
that's right hanky panky bumping uglies
the bed sheet tussle we all we all
wished with our entire beings that our
parents would stop doing it
but now that we've stopped
living with a low libido is not so nice
so why be afraid to talk about it
why female sexual dysfunction isn't the
boogeyman okay it's real and if you're
frustrated and that you rarely if ever
want to have sex hypoactive sexual
desire disorder also called hsdd could
be
the culprit in fact one in ten
pre-menopausal women experience
hsdd but
are you gonna just stand there and let
hsdd take all your sexy lunch money no
maybe
well you shouldn't meet addie or flim
answer and the fda approved a little
pink pill for certain pre-menopausal
women frustrated by their low sex drive
are you ready to learn more head over to
addy i dot com and schedule an online
visit today use code good for you and
check out at checkout also to find out
if addie could be good for you for only
ten dollars that's good for you at addyi
dot com adi add why a-d-d-y-i is for
pre-menopausal women with acquired
generalized hypoactive or low sexual
desire disorder hsdd who have not had
problems with low sexual desire in the
past and who have
low sexual desire no matter the type of
sexual activity the situation or sexual
partner the low sexual desire is
traveling to them and is not due to a
medical or mental health problem
problems in the relationship or
medicine or other drug use addy i also
addy is not for use in men
or to enhance sexual performance so your
risk of severe low blood pressure and
fainting is increased if you drink one
to two standard alcoholic drinks close
to your addy dose wait at least two
hours after drinking before taking out
your bedtime your risk of severe low
blood pressure and fainting also
increased if you take certain a certain
prescription over the counter or herbal
medications or have liver problems low
blood pressure and fainting can happen
when you take addy even if you don't
drink alcohol or other medicines do not
take it if you're allergic to any of the
other ingredients in addie allergic
reactions may include hives itching or
trouble breathing sleepiness sometimes
serious can occur common side effects
include dizziness nausea tiredness
difficulty falling asleep or staying
asleep and dry mouth see full pi and
medication guide including boxed warning
at addie.com
pi or call 844 pink pill learn about the
little pink pill addy at
dot addyi.com
now we are back to dita vontis
i love a full butt underwear it is so
much sexier to me and look at these on
the top
adjustable why is full butt so much
sexier i just like it i feel like i like
a thong back underneath like pants and
things where you need to not have
visible panty lines but i do brushing on
the back makes your butt look so good
bikinis and full back underwear and i
love
more of a reveal when you like pull them
off it's like and you know you wear the
garter belt under that so then you can
just be wearing only this
and also so if you have to go to the
bathroom you can just pull your
yeah right right right
see i got it i got a really it takes me
like a good 40 minutes to put on a
lingerie set a good 40 minutes i got a
stretch i guess i'll like like throw out
an l4
but my god these are so beautiful i feel
like these are going to be my
first santa this year
i'm obsessed with you i know we can't
keep you much longer
and tell me about your necklace okay yes
ma'am uh this do you want it
well it says ramona frank ramona frankie
king daisy these are all my animals oh i
want one like that yeah
with all your cat what are your cats
names berlioz and glamourpuss
and uh aleister who is my soul mate oh
my baby he died in 2020. he was like
instagram sensation
used to ride on luggage in the airport
oh my god i used to take him on tour
with me and he was amazing see there is
this new thing now where in addition to
having to deal with your own animals
passing getting attached to ones on
instagram you don't that you fall in
love with and then and then they die and
i'm like i can't be careful i had to
unfollow after after grumpy cat and
after the the marnie or the one with the
tongue i was like i can't yeah it's just
i can't do this like
yeah i can't be heartbroken by your dog
that lives in canada
you know it's just too much like i have
to you know what i mean i had to mute
like unfollow a bunch of dogs it was
like it was a weird day yeah i was like
why did you unfollow me i'm like i'll
donate just please like i can't fall in
love with your dog um next time you come
she's gonna work okay and we have all
sorts of surprises for you and her i'm
so fascinated by your reaction to her
though i know i'm really i love her i'm
so overwhelmed by you but i feel like i
real coming in i had so many questions
for you have so many like things but
your like silence and elegance and grace
has been the most interesting thing here
like just watching you like
not
just be relentlessly you this entire
time has just been really comfortable
around you really yeah
i don't feel comfortable around you
really oh god not at all i'm joking
joke i'm totally kidding i don't i'm
just i'm really fascinated by you and i
just i wish i had i'm glad we did it the
way but i do kind of wish i had spent a
little more time with you before this so
i was like prepared for how
uh
like like a pre-interview not just like
i i've just been i feel too comfortable
i've just been thrown by just how
i'm just
i'm just in awe of you wow
yeah i'm not usually like this okay but
wow i'm like i'm fangirling out a little
bit and i'm totally obsessed with your
energy
and just how how clear it is and and
what is the word like there's no
apologetic codependent
messiness around you okay wow do you
know where that is you know when
somebody started to say i'm very like
embarrassed but no but it's like the
it's like this is what i'm in therapy to
act like oh well i'm happy too
you know what i'm saying like you're
just so in your own body and i find
myself when i'm in a new situation
sometimes i'm still like do anything am
i fi and i just get a little like you
just come in and you own your space yeah
but i mean i'm here as a visitor if you
came to my house i'd be the same way
like gosh
yeah right right now okay and you're
welcome to come over i would i'd i'll
die i'll be awkward i'll pull up don't
be the one my sex
can you imagine if i did and you were
like whoa i'd be like bitch can we
switch yeah
i have uh there is a very famous um he's
more of a talk show host now a comedian
who collects the sex dolls that you put
in the tub
and warm up they're like
made of wax or something and they're all
over his home made of wow
and you put him in the bathtub to warm
up is this someone who remains nameless
yeah okay it's pretty known if you just
ask oh really yeah i'll google it i'll
tell you in five minutes
i'll tell you in five minutes it is like
a pretty like known thing i don't think
he's got a ton of shame about it but i
am kind of fascinated just the idea that
the guy's like putting it in the bathtub
like how badly do you need this to be a
mannequin wow i'm just trying to imagine
how that works even if you're like
trying to have sex with this
dead weight doll in a
bathtub how do you do that i think you
got to take her out and then she's warm
oh okay you put her in the bath and then
you take her out and she's warm and then
you and then on the bathroom floor
because it's like it's going to get cold
up probably yeah then you have a whole
you got to dry her off it's like because
then you're kind of like it feels like
you're taking care of your kids
that's where i feel like it gets weird
when you're drying her off and like
sitting around yeah totally it's just
you know men are can be caretakers i
mean a very it's very sweet to hear them
write about it because they'll be like i
had to buy her new pantyhose and they
didn't fit
like men that have dolls they can do
hair they can do makeup they are like
they're like what should i go to um
uh forever 21 to get the i shouldn't
have picked that store of all stores um
i hope they don't see their dolls the
best is when they name their dolls the
best is men getting sex uh dolls and
naming them it's always it's always like
amber
valencia like the names are always like
russian
um
like queens or something because they
think
they think it's like classy or something
anastasia and then there'll be one guy
that just names his like dot
no come on did you know that he's like
80. he's like hey is my girl dot like i
don't
like but it's always like like fantasia
anastasia plantation it's a piece of
it's a bro
and someone oh fantasia there's a singer
the singer yeah yeah and then it's
always like something so it's just so
funny to me that they pull this body out
of a box that is made out of silicone
and they're like wait what would you
like alexandra
what would you name your doll well not
bear claw a different doll okay if i had
one because i named her bear claw
because i did a joke in my last special
that was about how um
we get women's nicknames uh we get
called desserts a lot like honey sweetie
cupcake and my thing was if um it's
gonna this doesn't sound as funny now
that i'm just mumbling through it i
think i know it's coming it was yeah why
don't you call if you're gonna call us
desserts at least call us a cool dessert
like bear claw yeah um so that's why i
named her claw okay and uh if i had one
that was not
sexual
yeah a guy want a fun name like butter
or bubble bubbles yeah
butter is does it doesn't sound funny
well you can say i can't believe it's
some numbers
i can't believe that's not whitney
i don't know i like um i like name well
i don't know i like animal naming
animals flowers
and human names and then naming humans
not human names or like old older names
like from like i've always want to name
a human nora from doll's house ibsen's
dollhouse my favorite play and she like
got out of her circumstances so i like
nora
but that on the school yard
like toaster no or something really a
refrigerator no they make male ones too
right they do henry yeah henry henry
henry is his name that's his name yep he
has he comes with the name he comes with
the name that's henry yes i mean you can
change it if you want okay but he's a
henry now and the thing is with the hand
the ones that i know of and i'm sure a
lot is changing a lot of the male one is
being used for uh
men that are trying to figure out if
they are gay or not and they want to try
chaos not imagine i wouldn't even want
one because they can sleep with that and
then beat it up yeah women don't yeah
uh yeah women i mean yeah i had written
a bunch of jokes about that like we
already have a sex robots atm machine or
something i don't know i like we don't
like it would just need to like listen
or something and they couldn't get it
they haven't gotten it there yet i
didn't know they were robots now i just
i remember the real doll thing and
that's those are most of them now these
are custom made and they don't really
people don't really have these yeah it
seems and even mine is really you know
they're not going to take over anytime
soon we can't even get her right cheek
and her left cheek to do the same thing
at the same time but honestly that's
kind of where my face is going so maybe
maybe they just tried to give it bad
botox
it's called
foresight feel like chris christmas
whitney drinks a lot she always gets
that discount botox this is probably
what she'll be like
um you're such a dream thank you for
coming out here
um the orpheum i have it all up here
we will be there
there is honestly new year's eve is such
a nightmare this is the only thing i
would leave the house for besides doing
stand up it's funny because people spend
all day getting ready getting their hair
and their makeup done and stuff and
um you know i originally i was like oh i
should have an after party and then
nobody came they were all like great
that was fun 1205 i'm going home and
going to bed like very civilized in a
lot of ways yup yup yup which you know
it's kind of nice i've hired a beautiful
big
big band to be on to be part of the show
this year so i'm excited about that i'm
going to do some ballroom dance strip
tease oh my gosh
and you want me to just do like
a speech yeah just a tight vibe a toast
yeah a toast yes okay all right all you
know what i got intro yeah i got it at
the orpheum
do you want to sing a song with the band
let me i think i'll figure it out
do you have like an opener like do you
like an opening thing it's just a full
show we have like two it's two like 45
minute sets with a
20 or 25 minute intermission and it's
just um various different burlesque
performers and
variety acts just as many men as women
and
yeah is the entourage gonna be there
entourage will be there yet i'm already
trying to think of all the ways i'll
torture them um with those tiny little
outfits
okay like an elio
if you don't know how to find tickets we
have bigger problems uh uh google it
find it because i can't give out
specific um it's okay sometimes i'll say
ticketmaster or something that people
get like like what is it when you get
yes wendell swindled and then they're
like why'd you tell me to go to that
link and i'm like i didn't know it was
fake i thought interestwares.com was a
real site instagram and all the links
are right there look at that at
davonte's and if you want more deed on
instagram you can sign up for so close
oh
so close yeah so you remember yes yes
okay i gotta find you
what's that so close is like it's like
your close friends account yeah like
people subscribe and they can be on my
close friends so i just send them things
which is more i'm a little bit more like
hey you guys you know i i get i'm braver
it's you and i'm grateful hey guys i get
kind of i mean
mcdonald's what are you doing
like what are you guys doing like
anything yeah i just get like shy in the
general public because i feel like
there's you know i get like
plus also you you know like people will
take pictures and they'll use it for
press or whatever like tabloids or
whatever so i feel like so i have my
close friends list and you can just
subscribe to us like mine they take and
then photoshop dicks in my mouth oh yeah
when that happens
i try just like any time i do a photo
i'm like i'm like that's going to be
yeah there's going to be a dick in there
why did i why did i fucking post that
like i'm literally doing this to myself
because i'll like i don't know what to
do in photos so i'm just like i usually
open my mouth and i'm like god damn it
that's gonna be more it's gonna be a
couple dicks i feel like
um
i am obsessed with you i honestly like
just looking at
the careers of people that i admire like
people that just
did what they loved and became the best
at it i do not think you can fail
thank you do you know what i mean i mean
i yeah i just mean like and just talking
to you like how i mean just this isn't
an accident do you know what i'm saying
it's like when someone just commits to
being the best at what they do
i think they're unstoppable
i never it never occurred to me that i
was just gonna that it was gonna be a
career it was just like oh this is fun
that's what i like i'm totally like it's
like lightning struck it's fun because
there's just there's there's things
where i'm like here's what i would do to
be able to i think i could do that like
i cannot i'm just i'm just completely in
awe of you
and you have this energy about you
that's because a lot of times you meet
people that have created so much stuff
and become such icons and you they're
like hey they're just kind of like
stress cases and that's how they got it
all done i'm a stress case i'm like a
duck i'm like smooth sailing on the top
of my paddling like this underneath i'm
just like
this is such a perfect way to put it so
that you would just hide the the straps
yeah
very well the detail is insane insane i
mean that's what that's
detailed theater when you were like why
are those lamps two different colors and
they were like how did you
yeah but that's like it's but a blessing
and a curse but to be a perfectionist
and not
um
a nightmare to be around right is a very
you know what i'm saying
it is a hard thing it's hard to be a
perfectionist and not
like
be manic does that make sense yeah i
mean yeah i'm always i think i have an
audio book right now that's like how to
let go of perfectionism because it's
like i get very like obsessed with
yeah
the details as you should you know but
to be able to just like move through the
world with so much grace and i'm just
fat i am truly fascinated
well thank you for having me here i'm
fascinated by you too i'm just too shy
to say so i'm just like oh god you're
such a dream yeah you're such a dream so
i don't think either of us got cancelled
i don't think so i feel like we don't
yeah
anything i'm missing
um i'm sure this is going to be the real
problem they're like why are you showing
a handicapped woman as a sex doll i'm
like look because this is palsy is sexy
like no we're talking about you
i love you guys uh you know i end these
very awkwardly don't ride elephants i'm
gonna go put on more bras
[Music]
four four four
[Applause]